that's a hell of a difficult thing to do  right for a huge company to just pivot  i mean it's so interesting to because  we'll talk about your current work  it's like it's clear that pcs were  dominating for several decades  like desktop computers and then mobile  it's unclear it's a leadership question  like like apple under steve jobs when he  came back they pivoted multiple times  you know they build ipads and itunes and  phones and tablets and  great macs like like who knew computers  should be made out of aluminum  nobody knew that that they're great it's  super fun that was steve yeah steve jobs  like they pivoted multiple times  and uh you know the old intel they did  that multiple times  they made drams and processors and  processes and  you